so I grew up in Brooklyn New York so I'm
gonna get a full story I grew up in
Brooklyn New York where you know gun
ownership is taboo you know in the inner
city the problem is is that people have
guns and people die which is legit
that's just the way of life growing up
in the inner city and so the politicians
and the media feed this Narrative of oh
my gosh guns are evil so nobody can have
them the truth of the matter is is that
if law-abided citizens had the ability
to possess Firearms with mineral
restrictions minimal restrictions no
restrictions what you would see is the
criminal element would understand you
know what I can't
act crazy because I'm not sure who's
carrying the vast majority of people
just want to live in harmony and peace
with one another they're not trying to
cause problems but when the criminal
element understands that the politicians
restrict gun ownership to the degree
where normal people feel it's taboo and
it's the wrong thing to do it actually
empowers a criminal element it's it's
kind of sad because that's I just feel
like Common Sense obvious I've heard it
a million times throughout my life
that an arm Society is a polite Society
if people in the cities were armed and
criminals would be scared of them
because you have equal force to be used
against you but it doesn't seem to get
through to these gun control Advocates
and now we have Joe Biden coming out
with the what what was his slogan Let's
uh let's get the job done or was it
finish the job I don't really know what
he was talking about he was yelling too
much he was he was slurring a bit too
but he said let's finish the job ban
assault weapons right and they can't
even Define what it is so this goes back
to what I was just asking congresswoman
bobert right how do you affect change in
a positive direction with with through
logical lens to make things better if
your political opponents don't know what
they're talking about well the first
part is you know I always go back to
Gladiator I'm gonna date myself a little
bit you know I'm 44. that movie with
Russell what was it listen Gladiator was
that movie that's a good movie it was
that was that movie and you know the
advice in Phoenix the advice to
um you know to Russell Crowe maximus in
the movie was you win the crowd you win
your freedom and so on a on a
philosophical level politics hasn't
really changed
Politics the art of politics is really
about can you get enough people in the
body populace
in the in the population to be with you
if you can get enough of them to be with
you
then you can then you have the political
will to move the argument to move the
bill to move the policy but it if you'd
ever get the people to see your side and
be on your side you can't win your
freedom that's the way you can actually
in some respects break Washington loose
because for a long time you know as a
conservative the media is against you
you know that
Republicans largely have been terrible
at messaging we know that so it ends up
becoming people deciding to engage in
politics and policy of their own
volition of their own passions and the
nut I think that you know I guess the
new the new age myself bobert and others
Gates and others that we're trying to
crack is
is there the possibility to get
your average American
to look at our arguments and be like you
know what that Byron dude is right I
like what he's saying I think and that's
the pathway I think the internet helped
greatly but I also think there's a
there's an inverse reaction too because
you end up with these people uh one of
the examples of social media
manipulation I've brought up is that
imagine you're 10 years old in 2008
right Facebook is just coming into you
know popularity and prominence or it's
getting bigger and bigger and these
companies like BuzzFeed and Huffington
Post find out that you know what kind of
article gets the most traffic
police brutality 100 so they start
making more and more and more of it
right now you're a little kid and you're
on Facebook and the only thing you see
every single day is more and more videos
of police brutality rap songs about I
don't know if you ever you've seen that
rap song this is what happens when you
call the cops I mean I'm a hip-hop kid
so I even go back to NWA Ice Cube Snoop
you know that's how far I go back yeah
I'm A hip-hop kid I love hip-hop so
you're you're you're a little kid and
you're seeing this nothing but this for
10 years 10 years later you're 18 you're
ready to vote your whole world is shaped
around this idea that police are going
around mercilessly murdering people and
targeting black people and it's just an
extreme insane exaggeration built by
social media manipulation so as much as
the internet's empower the ability of
conservatives who tended to have a bad
mess bad messaging or were locked out
from the media you end up with people
who are living in a deranged State like
Trump derangement Syndrome from this
stuff like how do you reach these people
and
I mean how do you it feels like the
country's bifurcated the point where to
put it another way you've got the West
Coast wanted to ban gas vehicles you've
got some states banning child sex change
operations some states becoming
sanctuaries for child sex change
operations I don't see how you pull that
stuff together how do you bring these
cultures back together I mean look it's
very difficult but that's where programs
like yours come in you know I mean
bobert was like Hey Byron you got to
come in and do this podcast tonight I
said you know whose podcast are we doing
she's like let me tell you about them
it's great I said all right cool I'm in
I'm gonna do it cool you have to do
programming like this I think that
the way that our party has done
messaging is you deal with the
Washington Post the New York Times
MSNBC NBC CBS ABC they hate your guts
you know you're going to get a hard
interview when Fox came along 30 years
ago Fox was like a revelation for for
the conservative movement for the
Republican party just being honest it
was a revelation right yeah but because
young people taking information on this
thing at warp speed because I got three
kids they look at their phones they
don't even watch TV anymore so I try to
tell my colleagues all my guys
don't get me wrong doing interviews is
cool
but there's a whole nother uh ecosystem
you have to penetrate
how do you do it do you do it through
reels do you do it with shorts do you do
it with responses to some narrative out
of media and it's not just doing it once
it's not just saying oh I went on and
there's no disrespect to Sean Hannity
love to do a good dude but it's not just
doing a Hannity Prime Time Hit
it's are you in a rapid fire response
pushing narratives pushing messages
what's actually happening being able to
explain the thing in 90 seconds like you
you don't have 20 minutes and don't get
me wrong like look I'm about as eloquent
as they come people love listening to me
I don't got 20 minutes I got 90 seconds
to get this thing right but think about
even in Congress uh you had what five
minutes to question Twitter right how do
you how do you get through a deep
conversation to break down the issues
that are negatively impacting this
country if they're like your five
minutes begins now good luck well that's
why I try to change the rules so what
I've been talking to the chairman and to
the speaker was we got to get out of
this mindset of every member is
recognized for five minutes that's
ridiculous by the time you get warmed up
the time is over
and then the other thing is a lot of
members waste time because they're
trying to fill their time and then the
third piece is staff members write most
of the questions in most of these
speeches so you'll see the member like
this and they'll be reading a thing like
this and they'll never look at the
person sitting in the chair and their
eyes are down because they're reading it
you don't have an opportunity to engage
in a legitimate Dialogue on the issues
presented
so my my position has always been look
get rid of seniority recognition get rid
of the five minutes have the chairman
recognize members as they choose to be
recognized what you would have is a
dialogue between members a dialogue with
the witnesses then you can get into a
situation like that oh I don't have my
five minutes I got one question I threw
out a question ocasio-cortez does
whatever she does on the other side I
look at it like oh that's a bunch of BS
chairman let me in I come back fire back
that's how you get the dialogue moving
that's what Congress doesn't do right
because Congress is fixated on
doing your clip for a newsreel that
might show up in one of the network news
shows at night or maybe the New York
Times might report on it or the
Philadelphia Enquirer or whatever or the
LA Times we're in a different uh genre
in Media
and so you got to have that conflict in
a positive way to get the message out to
people to see what's really happening
what do you think about the the squad
how is your relationship with them so I
talked to some of them on the side you
know I just keep it professional
um again I grew up in the inner city so
for me
it's never personal until you mess with
like my personal safety or my family or
my money
you do that
now it's personal
everything else is business is that why
in Congress because people are getting
like basically bribed by you know
pharmaceutical companies they're whoever
they're they're what I call them
lobbyists that they actually feel like
you're threatening their money if you're
passing a bill that denies that's not
even it because the truth is about
lobbyists is they're going to write you
a check regardless what a lobbyist
really wants is access they want to be
able to be like look if I passed you a
five thousand dollar check if I call you
a staff or if I if I happen to have your
cell phone will you answer my call and
give me an opportunity to explain myself
lobbyists are counting votes which also
is what leadership in both Chambers is
doing they're counting votes that's all
they're doing I tell people at home all
the time look if you call my office just
you by yourself I'm not even gonna like
I don't even know that you called if a
hundred people called my office my chief
of staff knows and she's like hey Byron
uh we had 100 calls on this issue if a
thousand people call my whole office
knows what's going on and I definitely
know what's going on that's how this
works the lobbyists all they're doing is
trying to have an ability to have a
conversation with the member
if you have members who change their
opinions just because of what a lobbyist
says you got a weak member that person
probably needs to go home and not be an
elected official real talk right
but the issue is not just a lobbyist per
se when I talk about being able to talk
with members on the other side Squad
members
me and Jamal Bowman we talk football we
don't even talk politics we know we
don't agree on politics so we're talking
about the NFL we talk football and
because we talk football we have a an
ability to engage each other if there's
something popping up where a
conversation needs to be had
um with the squad members
for everybody who says oh Freedom caucus
members are always causing problems in
Republican leadership Squad members
cause problems in Democrat leadership
they do the same thing on the other side
but our politics are so different
that's why people think we're always at
odds with them they seem to be marching
more in lockstep with the rest of the
party these days though especially when
it comes to War I would argue that what
they've done on their side is they've
gotten their party till Marcia locks up
with them thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time